one of the world's most exclusive
holiday destinations the maldives
is now grappling with the surge in covet
19 cases
nearly 1400 new cases were recorded by
the island nation on tuesday
hovering near a record high that's
compared with less than 100 daily cases
reported just one month ago last week
the maldives decided to temporarily ban
travel from several south asian
countries as the region faces a massive
second wave tourists from other
countries with a negative pcr test
may still visit the maldives famed
resorts but they are not allowed contact
with the local population
and joining me for more now is the
minister of state
for health in the maldives and acting
director
general of health services dr shah maher
thank you for your time dr maher
what is behind this sudden surge in
coronavirus infections in the maldives
thank you very much we are in the
process
of uh evaluating um this sudden search
there are a number of factors
we believe is responsible for uh
the current surge one is uh
uh there are new variants that we
uh we are concerned about and currently
we are on the
uh investigation uh which variants are
there are
and also recently our
uh because of ramadan and a lot of
movements have been happening in uh you
know we
the measures are a little bit relaxed
for various reasons
so that may have had a influence on that
so um for for us uh for
um the actual cause for the third wave
that we have uh in maldives is not
entirely clear
but what we've noticed is from um
january
at the beginning of kovid after a year
we've had 20 percent increase in cases
recently
so we the numbers are as you know
roughly we have a population of 600
000 uh people in maldives
and every day we have 1 400 to 500 cases
being positive right now
so we have introduced some uh measures
to control the situation right uh you
talked about variance uh
is the widely circulating indian variant
one of the variants you're looking at
well we you know india being our
closest neighbor any um effect in india
we will obviously uh be um
cautious on on that so we have not uh
we have not identified any particular
variant we
from time to time we do send for genomic
sequencing
maldives don't have the capacity to uh
analyze a genetic variant so we do the
pcr testing and when we suspect we send
samples so we are currently
waiting um for that
information but we our
our regulation and the way we're working
we are assuming that that is a
possibility that we
we may have variants uh indian variants
in our community
and may be responsible for this surge
right where are you with the status of
vaccinations i mean last we heard the
roughly 60
of the population had received at least
one shot of a vaccine
i'm wondering if you think that this is
a vaccine-resistant variant you're
dealing with
well um you're right we are actually
very fortunate to have a large number of
our population uh vaccinated in fact our
eligible population 67 69 percent
uh is vaccinated with first dose over 33
percent
is vaccinated uh uh uh with second dose
completed the vaccination
um we we don't actually believe that
there is
that resistance but you know that actual
data to remain to be seen
we believe uh the the the
search is to do with more of uh
movement uh happening within the
maldives um
as well as uh that additional variants
might be circulating in the population
but there is no evidence
to show that um you know
the vaccines are ineffective to
the the new cases what we have actually
seen
is also uh the cases that are being
admitted to hospitals
um the the the people are more severe is
the people who
people who hasn't had the vaccination
right so that
you know there is protection and people
they are less severe
uh when they get the disease if those
who have had vaccination
and those who have died uh majority of
them have
have not received the vaccination right
dr sharma here the minister of state
for health for the maldives thank you so
much sir for your time
thank you very much my pleasure